اعتذروا قبل التنظير علينا !!
بلغة شديدة  اللهجة أطلقت الصين
هذه التصريحات ضد الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية،
اعتذروا! عن مليون قتيل في العراق،
واعتذروا عن الضحايا في يوغسلافيا
واعتذروا عن عبث ٢٠ عاما في أفغانستان
واعتذروا عن تدمير سوريا،
اعتذروا عن كل هذا ثم أرونا طلباتكم وأوامركم،
نعم هكذا رد التنين الصيني على التهديدات الأمريكية
فهل يكفي ذلك؟...
(طلبات غريبة دفعت المتطوعين  الأجانب
للهرب من أوكرانيا)،،
زلة لسان بايدن قد تشعل حربا عالمية ثالثة،
وحليف بوتين يحذر من حرب نووية كبرى،،
بايدن يستفز بوتين مجددا بالشتائم
فهل يصبر زعيم روسيا طويلا على هذه الأخطاء؟
نقطة قوة لموسكو في مواجهة العقوبات الغربية،
السويد تتخلى عن حيادها
وبوتين يلقن اليابان درسا قاسيا،
(رد التنين)
الصين لأمريكا اعتذروا قبل التنظير علينا!!.
رسالة قاسية أرسلتها الصين بعد اتصال هاتفي
بين بايدن وشي جين بينغ..
بكين، طلبت من أمريكا الاعتذار
عما فعلوه في يوغسلافيا والعراق وأفغانستان وسوريا،،
جاء ذلك بعد تهديد أمريكا للصين بعقوبات
حال اقتربت من روسيا، في محاولة لإبعاد
حلفاء موسكو عنها بأوراق الضغط الغربية،
فيما رفضت بكين إدانة العملية الروسية
في أوكرانيا، وقالت الصين أيضا أن التهديد الأمريكي
تدخل في شؤونها،،
وبكين لن تقبل أبدا أي إكراه أو ضغط خارجي،
وتعارض أي اتهامات لا أساس لها
أو مريبة ضد الصين..
فكيف ستكون ردة فعل الأمريكان بعد هذه التصريحات؟
(الهرب من أوكرانيا)
مقاتلون ضمن فيلق الأجانب ،
جاءوا إلى أوكرانيا متطوعين وخرجوا منها فارين،
وذلك بسبب معاناتهم من شروط كييف
فأول الشروط: أن يسلموا جوازات سفرهم
والتعهد بعدم مغادرة أوكرانيا إلا بعد انتهاء الحرب،
والمقاتلون الذين يرفضون ذلك تظل الأعين عليهم،
خوفا أن يكونوا جواسيس لروسيا ..
بينما يطلب القادة منهم قتل الأسرى من القوات الروسية.
كييف نفت قتل الأسرى لكنها لم تنفي تسليم الجوازات..
حتى من تطوع لأجل أوكرانيا تركها بسبب
معاملتها فمتى يتركها الغرب تماما يا ترى؟
(هل تدخل أمريكا الحرب ضد روسيا؟)
الرئيس الأمريكي جو بايدن يخبر الجنود في بولندا
أنهم ذاهبون إلى أوكرانيا،  والإعلام الأمريكي
يقول بأنها زلة لسان، فهل هي كذلك حقا؟
زلةُ لسانٍ فتحت الكثير من التساؤلات
فأمام عسكريي الفرقة الثانية والثمانين
المحمولة جوا، بايدن
تحدث بعبارة توحي
بأنه سيرسل جنودًا أمريكيين إلى داخل أوكرانيا،
وفيما بدت لغةُ الرئيس الأمريكي حمَّالة عدة أوجه،
تدخل البيت الأبيض سريعًا وأكد أن الولايات المتحدة
لن ترسل أي قوات أمريكية إلى أوكرانيا
وأنه لم يطرأ أي تغير في هذا الموقف،..
فهل هي زلة لسان من بايدن أم استباق لحرب عالمية؟
(حرب كلامية)
الرئيس الأمريكي يقول إن بوتين جزار
وأنه "لا يمكنه أن يستمر في السلطة"،
وهو ما أثار حفيظة الكرملين. وبينما تغاضت
موسكو عن كلام بايدن واعتبرته عجوز خرف
يهرف بما لا يعرف، وحذرت من الاستمرار
في التحريض من الطرف الأمريكي..
لكن خلال ذلك وللمرة الثانية..
..روسيا تضع قواتها النووية أو ما يسمى
بالثالوث النووي على أهبة الاستعداد،
مع تهديد شديد اللهجة لأمريكا والناتو،
فهل يتوقف بايدن عن إساءاته لبوتين؟
بعد ذلك أوضح مسؤول في البيت الأبيض
أن بايدن لا يدعو إلى تغيير النظام في روسيا،
مشيرا إلى أن الرئيس الأمريكي أراد أن يقول
إن بوتين لا يمكنه أن يمارس النفوذ على جيرانه أو المنطقة.
(انسحاب تكتيكي!!)
بينما قال الكرملين  إن "الأمر لا يعود إلى بايدن
كي يقرره، فرئيس روسيا ينتخبه الروس
(الأحداث والتطورات)
...
وزارة الدفاع الروسية: استهدف سلاح الجو الروسي
67 منشأة عسكرية في أوكرانيا،
من بينها موقعا قيادة.
وأضافت: دمرنا 3 مستودعات للأسلحة،
و11 هدفا للقوات الأوكرانية، و20 منطقة تخزين
معدات عسكرية.
واشنطن بوست: النفط والغاز هما السلاح الأقوى
في الحرب الاقتصادية الذي يستغله بوتين،
هذا من شأنه أن يمنح بوتين نقطة قوية
ليعرقل بها العقوبات الغربية....
فعائدات النفط والغاز هي أكبر ثغرة في العقوبات
الغربية على روسيا
...
السويد تتخلى عن حيادها وتعلن دعمها لكييف
بقاذفات صواريخ، و٥آلاف قطعة سلاح مضاد للدبابات
بعد أيام من تعليق موسكو محادثات سلام
مع طوكيو..مناورات عسكرية روسية
على جزر كوريل المتنازع عليها مع اليابان،
ونقلت وكالة إنترفاكس الروسية للأنباء،
الجمعة، عن المنطقة العسكرية الشرقية
في روسيا قولها إنها تجري مناورات عسكرية
في "جزر الكوريل" بمشاركة أكثر من 3000
جندي ومئات من القطع العسكرية.
موسكو تؤكد أن سيادة روسيا الاتحادية
على جزر الكوريل أمرٌ لا شك فيه،
في حين تصرّ اليابان على أنّها جزء من أقاليمها الشمالية.
حليف بوتين (نائب أمين عام مجلس الأمن الروسي)
وهو الرئيس السابق لروسيا ديمتري مدفيدف
يوجه تحذيرا للولايات المتحدة الأمريكية،
حال استمرت (بالمؤامرة طويلة الأمد
على بلاده تستهدف إذلالها وتقويضها
وتقسيمها وتحطيمها،)
الرئيس الأوكراني يطالب الغرب بجزء صغير
من عتاده العسكري لبلاده،
معتبرا ذلك ضروريا من أجل حرية أوروبا،
بريطانيا: العقوبات يمكن رفعها عن روسيا فقط
إذا سحبت قواتها من أوكرانيا، بينما أعلنت واشنطن
أنها فرضت خلال شهر عقوبات على أكثر
من 470 شخصية و196 كيانا في روسيا
الرئيس الأوكراني:
ما تطلبه أوكرانيا هو دبابات ودفاعات جوية
وأسلحة مضادة للسفن
أوكرانيا لا تحتاج أكثر من 1% فقط
من طائرات حلف الناتو و1% من دباباته
ولن تطلب المزيد،، هل أنت متأكد؟
واشنطن: قدمنا مساعدات عسكرية بقيمة
1.36 مليار دولار إلى أوكرانيا
خلال شهر من الحرب
قال زعيم الانفصاليين في لوغانسك إنهم يخططون
لإجراء استفتاء بشأن الانضمام إلى روسيا.
فر أكثر من 3 ملايين و800 ألف شخص من أوكرانيا
منذ بدء الهجوم الروسي، حسبما أعلنت الأمم المتحدة
مديرة صندوق النقد الدولي:
الاقتصاد الأوكراني سينكمش بنسبة الثلث
وروسيا تتجه لركود اقتصادي عميق
حاكم خاركيف:
• إسقاط مقاتلة روسية من طراز
"سو-34" بالقرب من منطقة إيزيوم.
• القوات الروسية قصفت المدينة 15 مرة
خلال الليل بأسلحة بعيدة المدى
انفصاليو دونيتسك: قواتنا فرضت سيطرتها
على 133 منطقة سكانية،
بما فيها فيرخنيتوريتسكوي، بدعم روسي.
هيئة مراقبة الاتصالات الروسية تقول إنها حظرت
موقع صحيفة بيلد (Bild) الألمانية
وزارة الدفاع الروسية قواتنا دمّرت خزان
وقود بأسلحة عالية الدقة، ومصنعا للإصلاح اللاسلكي
في لفيف الأوكرانية.
تشاويش أوغلو:
هناك قناة تفاوض خلفية بين كييف وموسكو..
وعلى كييف أن تنتهج سياسات متوازنة
وهي تدرك أنها لن تنضم للناتو
روسيا تستعرض إطلاق ٤ صواريخ من نوع كاليبر
على عدة أهداف أوكرانية من البحر الأسود
الدفاع الروسية:
الحفاظ على الجاهزية القتالية النووية الاستراتيجية
من أولوياتنا
..
اتصال سيجري بين بوتين وأردوغان.
لمباحثة الأزمة الأوكرانية
القوات الروسية تدمر قوافل للجيش الأوكراني
خلال تقدمها نحو كييف
هل تندلع حرب جديدة بين صربيا وكوسوفو؟
كوسوف طالبت مؤخرا بالانضمام إلى الناتو
بينما صربيا هي الدولة الأوروبية الوحيدة
التي لم تغلق مجالها الجوي أم روسيا
بين حرب أوكرانيا وروسيا يبدو أن حروب كثيرة
ستندلع فهل كانت الدول تنتظر حربا كهذه
لتجري حربها مستغلة انشغال العالم بالدب الروسي؟